[Music]
joining me today is an author and a
professor of philosophy at Portland
State University and a man who strives
to be a good human every day he ever
goes here and welcome back it's a great
pretty here thanks and thanks for the
striving to be a good human you'd never
know it from what people have been
saying about us absolutely well throw
you back me about you you really been
through the wringer in the last few days
and I would love to get to that and talk
about that I suspect we can get to that
but strives to be a good human being the
reason I threw that in there yeah
because that seems to me you were on the
show about a year and a half ago we had
never met before that we since become
very good for her again run every hit we
hit it off instantly yeah just like that
and when you were on the show and we'll
link to it down below so that people can
see the initial sit down I felt that it
was one of the episodes where so many of
the things that I had been thinking
about about the left about politics
about religion and but so many of the
things sort of all came to get hi
actually they really did and I felt I
felt richer after and I do often in some
interviews on interviews I feel Dumber
but this is one where I I felt richer
and since we've become friends but you
do strive to be a pretty decent I do is
you know you said how should I introduce
you in the beginning and iris I don't
ask that normally the only reason I
asked is because we're friends and I
yeah maybe there's some personal little
antidote or something maybe yeah and I
really you know it's I really just
striving to be a good person I think
that that's one of the things that
matter is that kindness that compassion
I think we've so lost it and acrimonious
there were so hyper-partisan were so and
the college craziness and everything
that's been going on is and at the
attacks and people don't give you an
opportunity to respond to those attacks
and the negativity on social media so
yeah I'm just trying to be a good guy
and that's trying to live my a good life
a good life so in the last couple months
right you lost your dad I did that was
the seminal event of one of the seminal
events of my life how do you stay a good
person throughout that not not that it's
not that losing someone's going to make
you a bad person obviously but a mom you
know you're still trying to work you're
still trying to be
a public person and to write know like
how do you manage not just going nutty
in the course yeah I had some health
issues I was in the emergency room three
times the last few months I have Crohn's
disease so that that's not doing me any
favors either without getting too deep I
mean you were in the hospital today yeah
yeah I don't know why tell it you know
that's my dad no that's my most up going
on but I can open about it no and I
think that that really does make every
moment of your life precious and when my
my dad died and my mom died I don't know
it's a kind of a combination of feeling
more circumspect and and I've always had
in the back of my mind
my parents approbation Oh what my dad
thank my mom thing and it's kind of
really given me an opportunity to I'm
trying to frame it positively it's
trying to given me me an opportunity to
reflect on what they did for me in my
life
and try to do that for my kids but yeah
when living navigating that reality when
your parents have died is very intense
it's very you know even little things
like you get in the car so always
getting the car in just call my dad or I
call my mom and I don't do that anymore
and I think one of the that's why I was
thinking today I don't like the idea
that someone passed it they they're dead
they've died there's a permanence to
that and that language and I am always
taking to myself like oh my mom would
like that my dad like that and it real
quick when my my mom died it wasn't
really into her funeral that I
understood that she died like really
grok tit because someone fell asleep in
her funeral and I thought god my mom
would think I totally would love that
and then I realized like I could never
tell her that I could never tell her
anything again and those pillars in your
life that you can't go to in times of
joy in times of stress you know as an
Oscar for another time for my Crosby's
my dad stayed up with me all night he
was there and that part of my life is is
gone now yeah so as a philosophy
professor and as a well-known and
outspoken atheist
when when you're challenged with
something like the death of a parent to
any of your beliefs get challenged I
mean
a moment at you know right after your
dad passed where you thought man I want
to believe or did you maybe have a dream
that seemed different
you know something like that because you
know you know my feelings on yours and
I'm not a believer in the traditional
sense and yet occasionally things happen
that I go what was that after my grandma
has to us very knows with sorry I had
some very vivid dreams that seemed to me
she was telling me something I'm not I'm
not saying i buy it for all it is but it
has some value you know did you have any
of that no have any of that no no I was
just incredibly briefed and I was it
mean it was just a shattering of a type
of reality for me and but it also made
me realize that it really is true that
every moment of life is precious you
just have to be so grateful go through
life with a sort of gratitude for the
experiences that you have so when you
hear someone like me that you know
pretty well say well you know my grandma
passed to him and I mean I can tell you
about the dream I was in hurt more I
mean she would she looked amazing she
was like glowing and she was wearing all
black and [ __ ] he's like green neon
streaks in her hair she was like running
in place really fast
there should be telling me how excited
she is and she has all these things to
do I mean it was and it was vivid and
powerful and whatever and so you hear me
say something like that as a
non-believer what do you think of that I
think it's totally normal and totally
natural I think different people grieve
in different ways and I think it was
when my grandfather died I had a similar
experience I had a hyper vivid dream
about him I think these moments in life
life death they're really they give you
a kind of clarity sometimes but they
also get so here's for so for my dad
when when he had died I was holding my
dad's hand in his at the end of my mom's
hand at her death so I was incredibly
fortunate you know they saw me into the
world I saw them out out of the world
I was just irreconcilable I mean I was
just so I was a complete mess I was
solving the woman who comes in the
social worker what have you said you
know normally we have grief counselor
and normally I would odds but suggest to
say but in your case I really think you
have succeeded grief counselor I'm
sending super studies earlier
councilor and writers and I think part
of that was so hard for me is precisely
because they don't have those
metaphysical beliefs like that's the
finality like that's it so we're there
so then did you have moments through
these so you didn't yeah I guess you're
saying you really didn't have a moment
where suddenly you thought maybe I got
this wrong or or I want to believe in
something that I can't prove but you
know I really it's really that locked
for you like oh no it's not locked I
just never borrowed my hope for anything
you know I never I never have a great
life oh yeah brother is my hope for
anything yeah it's true though I mean I
never and then you go through the long
you know I was living his house I was
driving his cars was closed because
right after we did the event with
christina hoff sommers the next day that
i went out there to see him but yeah it
was fortunate and you know one thing
that people really don't want to talk
about I think the left and the right has
their own blind spots but parenting I am
absolutely convinced is a prophylactic
to bad behavior good parenting and if
you look at the data kids are more
likely to commit violent crimes if
they're in a certain age group I just
read this in my resume math ones
manuscript about violence and if there
are males and if there's no adult male
president at home and just as the left
doesn't want to acknowledge that and
talk about that so too does the right
have particular blinders about
structural and quality and such but I
think parenting and good parenting and
being thoughtful and what that means
when I was when I was driving down here
the driver told me that I'm not going to
mention what country she was from like
50,000 emails oh yes these people and no
no did you pick a give me the same
hemisphere Southeast Asia okay it was
telling me that they come from a
traditional family and I asked why
doesn't your why don't your kids go to
see your ex and she said well he used to
spank them I thought why I've never
raised my hand to my children ever I
have raised my voice on the occasion
I've never lost my temper it doesn't
speak to to me I think Denmark smacked
me once or twice in an argument more
than that but that's the other thing
it's this idea about verbal via
it's the idea it's a complicated but I
think parenting
I think we've overlooked how important
that is the only thing one thing since
we're talking about this and plan on
talking about this I have no plan here
yeah the nurse said something really
interesting to me she said I bet you he
was a wonderful father to you and I said
well you say that to everybody and she
said actually no I don't I I can tell by
the way the kids treat their parents
when they come to the hospital and this
it was so sad so I would walk into this
hospital every day and I would see all
these people who were literally dying
and they were alone and they had nobody
and it just made me what kind of a
loneliness you know yeah is that the
funny thing about non-belief that you so
obviously had a transcendent experience
yeah but it's all based in actually what
happened so a lot of times in reality
like I had a father he was a physical
person he lived in my home he raised me
all in this you think so I I so what did
I do when my father died after you know
sobbing and the first person I called
was my my childhood friend like the next
person who had known me for the longest
time and he cheered me up and it was
good or he tried to you know that's
connected to the family thing don't you
think I've mentioned this a couple of
times lately that I think now at 41 next
week I started to really understand
thanks I started to understand why the
family thing is so important that I'm so
proud that my parents had been married
for 40 some-odd years and I still go
home to the same child at home and my
family friends are all there my best
friend in the world is still the same
guy that I met for kindergarten remember
as well that those connections have
incredible value they were totally
that's what you know what is the meaning
of life well you know whatever you make
the meaning will SP but Aristotle talks
about that and here's what I would throw
out to you and to the audience is that
you can have the richest deepest most
rewarding friendships if you are a
person of virtue and the person with
whom you're friends with is a person of
virtue eresources is the highest form of
friendship between two virtuous people
yeah and
we know what does that entail and it
really does entail a kind of Greek
parasya speaking truth in the face of
danger so and I've told you a few things
and you told me a few things hey I think
you're wrong about this so what have you
and if that is sufficient to decide that
we're going to part ways then either a
friendship wasn't that strong in the
first place or I would like to think
that we have the sort of relationship
that we can be completely honest with
each other and even really I wouldn't
spare your feelings about something
frankly yes which is what you and I want
exactly a true French right and then I
would expect that you would expect that
I wouldn't spare your feelings that I
would just say hey look man this is how
it is you did this and I have to say and
then whatever it was I was telling you
about this right before we started so
without even saying this the sex or name
of the person certainly or anything like
that I got into a bit of a argument with
a friend of mine a public person just
yesterday and we really got into it on
the phone and I made it clear and I've
done this a couple times lately made it
clear with people that even if were Yap
eclectically or angry at each other
she's not going to end the friendship at
least for me awesome and I feel very it
that comes very easy for me to say that
I a really does and I don't know why
that's so hard for other people to do
that we're so now willing and maybe it
is a social media thing in a short
attention span thing or something like
we're so willing to just shred things
that we've had yet lends itself to a
really interesting question
what would be since we're talking
personally if I ain't yeah what would be
a deal-breaker for a relationship and I
was at dinner with my family a few weeks
ago and my son you've met my son yeah I
did almost always keep my family's name
stuff on it
started talking about one of the things
he's learning about in school is gender
and social constructs and sex changes
and he said to my wife if dad decided to
become a woman would you still be
married to him and my wife without an
instant of hesitation said no and both
my children were flabbergasted but they
couldn't they could and then they kept
pressing her and she said basically you
know this isn't what I signed up for and
and it just made me think
so what are
limits of friendship like what would the
limits of friendship I mean I can think
of a few things well if you took if I
found out that you murdered somebody
yeah cold-blooded murder or you had done
something so duplicitous directly
related to me chief or even even I would
have mean even to someone else or I'm
going to make a scale like but what if I
started filling my pockets when you're
in the kitchen with grapes as I saw and
great I told you could have anything
else I know I know right the funny thing
is we have a relationship I in a
position anyway let's go so so like what
if I went to your bedroom when you
around and went to your drawers like
there are there are what you know with
what those limits are different but I
would I suggest that it really comes
down to virtue and Trust and those sorts
of relationships give your life so much
meaning and are so fulfilling and it's
so profound they make for a life worth
living and that I think what we need to
put front and center in our lives and
even the stuff on addiction is
fascinating or addiction medicine doctor
and she gave this really interesting
presentation about how one of the the
reasons that people become and stay
addicts and all the studies and this is
Automator of expertise but basically
these still do Studies on rat parks and
when rats are given wheels and fun
things habit rails wherever rats like
they're much less likely to choose
narcotics than if they're not and one of
those things is these relationships that
we develop and we nurture throughout our
lives and I guess I would like to be the
sort of person for whom being a person
of integrity and virtue and having those
deeply fulfilling relationships enhances
my life and my friendship and then when
you call me and you say hey this is up
thanks for that I appreciate you did
this and that was a massive dick move
thanks I appreciate that so I know we've
talked about that we've definitely
talked about this privately but I think
we may have talked about it last time
also but I think would be good to each
other if someone does exactly what you
just said find that virtuous life but
needs to do it through belief yeah but
does the exact same thing do you think
that that is somehow still an inherent
problem with with the proper not the
proper way to be a human but yeah what's
the problem if somebody does that well
there are two to two issues with that
one is what's the problem does that
cause a problem with your relationship
to somebody so I have a friend who's not
only is he a hardcore Christian he
writes children's books trying to
indoctrinate people into Christian Phil
Vischer the guy from vegetales beyond
very good friend of mine grabs and such
so this shows you can be friends with
some weekend and then I've confided here
about things and I trust him
and I have told him and no uncertain
terms
I think he's harboring a not a
misconception but a delusion about the
nature of reality and we've had a civil
to know one through fisticuffs no and we
talked about that in the context of our
friendship but that wasn't sufficient
for him to end the fall I never had any
idea we could tell you what to say that
wasn't sufficient for him to withdraw
from the friendship and the friendship
and that's a core belief and that's an
antithetical belief to what I've devoted
my professional life is to helping
people think clearly and critically and
overthrow dogma and ideology and morally
motivated reasoning but I think the
problem the problem with that is it
depends on what you want have what your
relationship to truth was to what you
think it should be there would be
something to me if somebody was friends
with me and a genuine friend and a
virtuous friend only because they feared
that if they would not do that they
would go to hell there would be
something suspect in that for me but
what if it wasn't that what if they just
had some booze you know what I mean like
whatever it is or they just had some
belief that karma prove their Cartwright
okay Karma's agree they just believed in
karma what they're going to put out
there is going to come back to them yeah
thus because of that they become the
virtuous type of person that aspire to
be it's a great question I think I've
shifted my stance on that over the years
I guess I'm having trouble with the
question because I don't really think
someone can truly be virtuous if they
Harbor beliefs based on a faulty
epistemology right so we could sorta get
a lot all right but my definition of
virtues right but let's just say that's
the case would the world would be better
off in human flourishing would be
contributed to if more people had this
false belief view than if we resorted to
this Hobbesian state yeah I guess the
problem would be if they alone believed
that and didn't try to institutionalize
that I think it would be it would be
less of a problem than I would have said
even two or three years ago yeah and I
think perhaps and I'll watch the video
again myself
yeah I think you might have answered
that a little bit differently some which
shows a flexible mind do you ever fear
that as a public person you say things
you tweet things you do interviews you
go on podcast all those things that
people are gonna burn hi you see he two
years ago he said something else and
it's like they they just want to get you
so so that that should what we really
need to of that should be a virtue it
should be a virtue that you change your
mind I will admit it's a hard for me to
admit but it's true it's so difficult
when you're constantly under attack and
constantly under siege to say it's far
more difficult not only to say I made a
mistake but like look I really thought
about this and then you get that's why
I've stopped reading my Twitter mentions
or Facebook I'm not about any of it able
because it's just so filled with hate
and rage and even if you look at the
terms we use the more valence it turns
out like flip-flopping flip-flopping is
a negative thing like you change your
mind but you should change your mind if
you're commander in chief and the
situation on the ground changes you
don't have access to that
oh you flip flop about troops in Iraq
about Guantanamo well we live in a
dynamic world where things are in flux
and they change but I have I have found
I have definitely found that being that
sort of person who's not willing to
change my mind but the open on open
admission of that on Twitter or Facebook
has become more difficult as people ramp
their personal slanders and attack yeah
so I'm I'm very aware of that dying to
talk to you about this yeah
dying to talk to you about what's been
going on with you I've had some strange
things going on we'll get there in just
one second okay so you also had another
sort of attack on you it was sort of
similar to what I had on me but that's
but I think you're really onto something
there that I don't think it is someone
you know sometimes people will say well
you said this three years ago I used to
be like this now look at some of my
tweets when I was a far left professor
yeah nobody used to make fun of white
people for this item yeah you're not
proving me into what are you trying to
prove you're proving that yes I evolved
right you change your mind and I wow
this guy had tooken information and as a
result that isn't the right rational
people to that's what right that's what
you're supposed to do but you're also
right about the the other point which is
that when you're under attack from
people when you feel like everything
you're going to say everything that
everything not having those nice moments
of maiya culpas yeah contrition you know
what else you stopped doing which is
interesting you stop asking questions
and and you might ask the questions
yourself but you you don't want to
articulate those questions or you don't
want to articulate those rebuttals
because you know you really don't want
to receive 500 emails and shift through
all of them telling your [ __ ] head and
you should go die and kill yourself and
people write your name and the walls or
not CA so you stop doing that I mean
like you give an example I was this film
I was in with with Michael's femoral
reasons to believe and I made a comment
about [ __ ] hats these people haven't
[ __ ] Hannigan any look like we this is
not the image you want to portray and
someone I got an unbelievable amount of
just crazy talk about that but one of
the things I thought was I almost said I
I came so close to saying do you think
Martin Luther King would have been more
respected or less respected if you had a
[ __ ] hat on I mean it would have been
the perfect thing to say but I didn't
say it because I didn't want hundreds of
emails and we don't me being racist yeah
so I think we're in a precarious
situation right now and I think Sam is
getting this crazy amounts
asking questions opening conversations
we need to have those conversations we
need to ask those questions you're about
to Harrison yes yeah well you know yeah
Charles Mario even carry columns the guy
whom the the ante sugar guy so what do
you do then if you were in my position
or in Santa's position when I see some
articles written about and so will Rubin
talk to this guy or didn't hire this
down they think this and Rubin didn't
ask them this and all this up Sam gets
this too by the way I mean box did a oh
yeah really hatchet job it represented
women charles murray talked about salon
hit pieces and and write and slate just
wrote something about you we're going to
talk about the conceptual penis shortly
and what happened with what's on but all
of those things they add up to us not
having anymore conversation because at
some point it's just like alright well
then I'll just talk about okay blade
I'll just talk to well it's not that
I'll talk to people I agree I'll just
talk to people who say nothing that's
right because then I've completely
insulated myself right no one will
really so they don't I think what we
need to do I think we need to figure out
everybody James Lindsay actually gave me
this idea and I think it's absolutely
right
co-author of the conceptual penis
analysis we need to figure out whose
voice matters certain people matter and
in general this hate and vitriol comes
from the least accomplished people who
you need there's a really nice
Nietzschean frame to talk about this
their view there's kind of I'm
oversimplified but but they're slaves
their situation reality is they're
slaves and they discharge these primal
urges on people it's like the
Australians have this term tall poppy
syndrome when that something grows high
you just cut it down as Rueben grows and
subscribers and the twelve I just cut
Ruben down you know pockets kind of that
Nazi white supremists homophobe yeah so
we gay married you not the on the book
right I don't know but it's over all but
we have to figure out whose voices
matter yeah and then we need to we need
to have those friendships of virtue so
when people come to us and say something
we can really listen but the way to not
do it is to look at as you've said
repeatedly to look at an egg on Twitter
yeah it's probably a twelve-year-old in
there
but we just can't take those voices
seriously
[Music]
you